[Music]
i study
this field called quantum physics which
is one of the most fundamental theories
that we have about physical reality
so microgreen is in in quantum computing
which is a theory that was proposed a
while ago
to use the effects of quantum theory to
power computing machines
quantum computers have become more or
less a mainstream thing
so theoretical thesis like me are
interested in looking
at what's ahead of that and out of this
field of quantum computing
came a number of new proposals to take
the laws of physics forward from from
that where they are now
and one of them is this thing called
constructor theory which is the
theory that i'm working on at the moment
and broadly speaking this is a new mode
of explanation to
understand physical reality in a way
that's
deeper and broader than what physics has
done so far
the deepest question is whether it's
possible to find
a more fundamental mode of explanation
for physical reality than the one we
already have
currently the best you can do if you're
a theoretical physicist
is usually to find a dynamical law
that can be applied to the whole
universe and given the initial
conditions of the universe can let you
know what the universe will do at some
point
in the future or in the past this is a
very powerful scheme so it's been around
since
you know galileo's and newton's times
but it does not capture
some aspects of physical reality that
are very important they require an
explanation
they exist out there but they can't
quite be fit into this mold
and one of these things is information
so the
the traditional way of explaining
physics
um can talk about information in in ways
that are approximative
and not very exact we can't quite
capture the the laws that
underlie information itself so i think
this was one of the
the the key motives behind
the you know proposing constructor
[Music]
theory
the most important part of physical
theory is in what it forbids
a universe where everything is allowed
is
not as interesting as one where only
some things are around another are not
the reason why that is is that as soon
as you say that something isn't allowed
or is
is impossible um then
there is an explanation that comes with
that
and um this explanation is is laden with
significance it has a lot of insight
in into physical reality there are a
number of examples that you can think of
one is
law like first law or thermodynamics
that says that energy has to be
conserved okay
and this law says that something is
impossible
meaning a perpetual motion machine is
impossible and it has a very powerful
very wide reach because just by stating
that
without actually working out
trajectories of atoms or
specific particles you can rule out
a whole set of phenomena just because if
they existed
they would permit a machine of that kind
which
is not allowed and so this is the same
logic that is behind behind constructed
theories
laws and and principles so constructors
here instead of using dynamical laws
and trajectories and initial conditions
takes statements about what tasks or
transformations are possible and what
are impossible and why as fundamental
ones
and then it derives explanations about
the rest
from those statements taken as
fundamental so this is a very powerful
switch
and it can achieve a number of very
interesting things
all in one go just because you change
the mode of explanation
we can capture phenomena that with the
traditional conception we could only
capture in approximative ways so these
are
phenomena related to information
phenomena related to
life so regularities underlie production
and
organization of information within
biological systems
and phenomena that have to do with work
and heat and then
another thing can happen there is this
problem that
we don't have yet a unique proposal for
a successor
for both quantum theory and general
relativity because these two theories
that are the most fundamentals we have
at the moment clash with each other
and there are some regimes where
experimentally
both are important but because they
clash
we need a a different theory that merges
both
to to be able to make predictions so the
principles of constructive theory are
very useful in these regimes because
given that they don't rely on a specific
dynamical law allow you to still make
predictions
and explain what's going on this is very
promising because it can
allow us to design new experimental
demonstrations that
we wouldn't otherwise be able to
conceive of and the the bet that we are
now trying to win in a way is to
make progress in some of these areas
where the traditional approach doesn't
quite work
by using this different radical
switch that constructed theory has in
formulating the laws of physics
and if that works then you know this is
a
great step forward because we have a
whole new array of tools that we can use
in order to understand physics and
physical reality
[Music]